في سن الثلاثين ، شعر ديف كونواي
بانخفاض مستوى طاقته ، لقد كان متعبًا في كثير من الأحيان
ولم يتمكن من الارتداد كما كان معتادًا ،
وعندما أتحدث إلى الناس حول هذا الأمر ،
سيكونون مرحبًا بهم في
التقدم في السن يومًا ما في العمل.  بذل
نفسه وشعر بغثيان خفيف ،
اعتقد أنه كان إجهادًا حراريًا في
البداية ولكن الأعراض استمرت وبمرور
الوقت أصيب بحرقة في المعدة
وضيق في التنفس عندما لم
يتحسن تم تشجيعه على الذهاب
إلى الطبيب بعد رؤية
ضغط دمه  تم إرسال كونواي على الفور إلى
غرفة الطوارئ حيث كان لديه
مخطط صدى القلب أي شيء أقل من 40
يعتبر قصورًا في القلب وكنت في العاشرة
يقول كونواي إنه مصاب بثلاث سكتات دماغية في
المستشفى ، ثم
تم اكتشاف انسداد 100 في أحد الشرايين الرئيسية.
كانت الأعراض السابقة في الواقع علامات
على نوبة قلبية Widowmaker
قال طبيب القلب الذي أتعامل معه إنه لو لم أحضر عندما
فعلت ذلك ، فمن المحتمل أن أذهب إلى
الفراش في تلك الليلة ولم يستيقظ أبدًا.
كل شخص
بغض النظر عن عمره لمعرفة الأعراض
بما في ذلك عدم الراحة في الصدر أو الألم الذي
ينتشر إلى الكتف الخلفي والرقبة أو
ضيق الفك في التنفس غثيان عسر
الهضم التعب الشديد هناك
شيء جديد تمامًا
ولا معنى لذلك فأنت تريد البحث عن
طبي فوري  بعد خمس سنوات ،
ركز كونواي على أسلوب
حياة صحي ، أدركت أنني سعيد
لوجودي هنا اليوم من أجل الصحة الدقيقة ، أنا آندي
جاثر
[موسيقى]